Three best friends of Jesus.
Number one Peter passionate and courageous,
but also impulsive.
He was known for his great commitment to Jesus,
although there were also moments of doubt,
denial, and lack of faith.
No.2 John known for his deep sensitivity and love.
He was very close to Jesus
and was identified as
the disciple whom Jesus loved the most.
He was noted for his devotion
and spiritual understanding.
No. 3 James.
Together with his brother John,
he was part of Jesus's inner circle.
He was known for his steadfastness
and leadership in the early church,
being considered a man of great faith.
These friends shared a special connection with Jesus
and played important roles in spreading
the Christian message after Jesus's death.
If you like Christian content,
I invite you to follow me for more.